Let's talk a little bit about asking good questions on
the forum. These are just some best practice guidelines to ensure
that you get the best answer that you're looking for.
First, try searching for answers. Before posting your question on the
forum, first search to see if anyone else has asked
the same question. You also might try Google to see if
you can get an answer that way. If that doesn't
work, go ahead and start a new post. You also want
to be specific when asking a question and
posting your problem. For example, if you're having trouble
with the problem set question, let the course staff
know what steps you've taken. So they can reproduce
the problem. State what you expected to see and
what you got instead. Finally, you might want to provide
details about the machine you're using. Make sure to
use concise and informative subject headlines. Include the important
details in the subject header so others can quickly
grasp what your post is going to be about. Note that
you're limited to a hundred characters in a subject
line on Piazza. And only the first 30 to 40
characters are visible in the summary view. So make
sure to put the important keywords first. Finally, be courteous.
A little courtesy never hurt anyone. If you find the
solution, make sure to follow up and resolve the issue.
And thank people who helped you. This brings up
another point. If you see a question that you
yourself know the answer to, feel free to chime
in and help out your classmates. Now let's talk a
little bit about what not to do. Don't post
answers to graded assignments, or even ungraded assignments on
the forum without first talking to the instructor. Don't
ask others to debug your code without giving details of
the problem that they should be searching for. Depending
on your class policies, your instructor may restrict you
from posting code at all. Make sure to ask
your instructor in advance before posting large sections of
code. Each class is a little bit different about
the policies around posting code and other sorts of
information. When in doubt, please ask your instructor for
specific guidelines about what is allowed to be posted.